Alison: Sorry I've just got this mental image of Tobes cosplaying a grown up, it's okay.
*intro music*
John: Hello everyone and welcome to the very 92nd episode of Octothorpe, a podcast for science fiction and science fiction fandom, which is coming to you on the 14th of September, 2023.
I'm John Coxon, Alison: I'm Alison Scott Liz: and I'm Liz Batty.
John: And we have a bevy of letters of comment, a veritable feast.
Alison: Are we going to talk about them all?
John: Dave Mansfield wrote in to tell us about how they use transcription for podcasts and we did ask people to do that so thank you Dave.
We then completely ignored it for a month but you know that's professionalism.
Basically Dave says that he makes references to transcripts of Freakonomics when he's being a thought leader on his office intranet.
So you know if we did transcripts more people might quote us.
Oh no.
Alison: I mean I know how I use transcripts on podcasts, which I don't know whether I said when we were talking about this, which is that podcast transcripts are searchable so often I am searching for information and I discover that somebody has discussed the things I'm interested in on a podcast.
And I can read the transcript and if it looks exceptionally interesting I can also listen to the podcast.
John: Obviously all of our episodes look exceptionally interesting, that's the Octothorpe guarantee.
Alison: But not to a kind of Googlebot thing, right, because they're not indexing it.
John: Googlebot, if you're listening, write in!
Liz, any thoughts on Dave Mansfield?
General trustworthiness, would you hire him for a job?
Liz: I mean I don't want anyone to use our transcripts to become a thought leader. I would not recommend that as a method of becoming a thought leader.
I would just say he's cosplaying a thought leader, well I don't know.
John: Are we thought leaders in the science fiction fandom?
Alison: I don't think we are.
John: So I went to a thing on I went to influencer training, and thought leading basically means putting opinions on the internet.
Alison: Who knew?
John: And I do that a lot.
I think Liz is the thought leader.
Liz: Gold leader.
John: Yes, gold leader.
Liz: I'll be gold leader.
John: I'm Rogue Nine, which two people listening to this podcast will get the reference and one will not enjoy that he did.
The best kind of reference.
Liz: I've just googled that and I realize- I realize what you mean.
There's a podcast called the History of Rock Music in 500 songs by Andrew Hickey and I noticed when I was putting in my podcast feed that it has the transcript of the entire episode in the show notes.
Which is really I think going above and beyond.
I just need to read the show notes.
I don't need to listen to the podcast.
Although it is a podcast about rock music, so you do need to listen to the podcast.
John: We also heard from Nick Hubble who said he was listening some time after the event but he wanted to point out that we really don't want to see a transcript of the Clarke award jury conversation from the last year because, Nick reports, it was all in the eyes.
And this is a friggin wonderful mental image of just six- like how many people are on the Clarke panel? Five? Six?
Liz: Five I think.
John: Just all like gazing at each other meaningfully until they decide to give the award to Venomous Lumpsucker.
And I'm wondering how you convey ecological collapse with your eyes.
It's like sad, a little tear rolling down one cheek.
Thank you very much Nick.
Duncan McGregor also on Mastodon says the spoilery horn sounds way more like a didgeri-read-it.
Which might be a joke that works better in text but I liked it.
Thank you Duncan.
Alison is - she laughed and now she's wincing and now she's chortling again and I think she's genuinely very conflicted by that joke Duncan so well done.
Alison: Quite.
John: And he also says he was not old enough to really notice Oh Superman when it came out but he certainly laughed at Alison's joke in Octothorpe so he's not sure if he's old or not.
Age is in the mind or in the references you get. On the subject of Oh's and also a small competition, can anyone discern what the Oh was?
Because it wasn't the Oh Superman bit that I used as the episode title, so if you can find the actual Oh's I'll buy your beer.
Peter Sullivan tries to guess what the context will be for our episode titles before listening and this time he was sure there was going to be a discussion of the merits of castling queenside in chess which is O.O.O. in descriptive notation.
And he wasn't sure why any of us would have especially truculent opinions on the topic.
So, anyone - castling queenside in chess?
Alison:  Mmm. Oh yes.
John:  What, chess? Agreed.
Alison: Yeah. Chess very complicated. Hard game for clever people like Peter Sullivan.
John: But thank you very much for writing in Peter.
Ersatz Culture wrote in and noted one twist on the Netgalley thing is that to create an account you have to pass a capture hosted by Google and notes that might pose problems if you live in China.
Alison: Yeah interesting point I have not considered, we did not raise that, but yes.
John: I will say I did apply for various Netgalley things and I did get approved for all of them but also in the thing they were like, well, what kind of journalist are you and I was like, I have a podcast which is nominated for a Hugo award.
Alison: You are a gonzo journalist, that's another one for our older readers.
John: Oh interesting that's like, what do we call him, Warren Ellis's Transmetropolitan, that's about gonzo journalism.
Alison: But Hunter S. Thompson.
John: Reference.
Ah.
John: For some reason when anyone says someone's a gonzo journalist I just imagine that they're a journalist with no trousers on and I don't know why.
Alison: Journalism without claims of objectivity which is indeed all of podcasting.
John: Yes.
But I am wearing trou- well my shorts.
I would be very interested listeners if any of you have applied to Netgalley who do not host a Hugo award finalist podcast how you got on, because I suspect my sample size may be skewed.
Alison: Yeah no I've got my Netgalley stuff as well, I think all of it.
I just have infinite numbers of books to read as well because now I have a policy that if a book is sitting in paper or I'm trying to get it in paper from the library and it turns up on my Kobo for 90p I just buy it for 99p on the grounds that it is more trouble to
go and get it from the library than 99p's worth.
So I just have tons of reading, I'm still not reading that fast.
This might be prefiguring my pick but I have finished all my prerequisite reading before I can start reading the Hugo lnovels now.
John: Yes, we will we will come back to that later (foreshadowing).
So Juan Sanmiguel also wrote to us that Juan managed to check out a copy of the Cyberpunk 2077 graphic novel and can report that the version in the packet is the full version.
So if you were wondering then now you know. Thank you very much Juan for writing in I think that's a first time writer, as I think is Nick, so hello first time people.
Ersatz Culture and Arthur Liu who is one of the co-editors who is nominated for fanzine as part of the Journey Planet big mind meld have put up the fan writer and fanzine categories for download in both Western countries and in China.
So if you do want to read, you know, writing by fans when you vote in the Hugos you can do that and we will put a link to this in the show notes.
And yeah because Chengdu you haven't put them online for some reason.
Alison: I have got issues 12 and 13 I think it is of Zero Gravity which is the Chinese fanzine that is nominated or it's a finalist for the Hugos.
It's in Chinese but it's actually pretty machine translation is getting better you know, I ran chunks of it through Google and found it perfectly readable and understandable and as it was talking about stuff like the development of science fiction
in China which is something quite interested in it was it was all perfectly readable and interesting so if that's something interesting I believe you can now go and get that from that link.
And then Chris Garcia accepts the cage match with Abigail. Abigail has not responded so we assume that she accepts tacitly, when we next run a convention will have this on the program, obviously. Chris says he always knew it would end up with Abigail and him in a cage match.
As was foretold in the ancient scrolls.
He also comes up with lots of different options for España's podcast or España's opinions podcast.
Names could include "Sheriff don't like it", "She's not angry just disappointed" and "Opinions and well curated swear words".
Alison: I'd like to see the non-explicit version of España's opinions podcast.
John: I mean that's like- I would I would like to see a world without war or famine but neither of us are going to get those things.
Alison: It's in the edit right, you'd have to edit it with lots of sound effect.
John: How? So my favourite piece of fan art that anyone ever ever drew which I'm very-
Alison:  Oh no, I know.
John: -is Jason Shacket drew a doodle of España which is entitled "España at rest" and it is her sitting on a sofa and it is captioned "Shut the fuck up asshole motherfuckers".
And that is accurate, that is España when she is Zen.
I love my wife very much.
Alison: Can we put that art in the pod so that other people will understand that.
John: Yes I can dig it out.
And also Chris obviously writes in to say that he got the Oh Superman joke and then follows up with the story of the time he met Laurie Anderson.
Alison: Yeah no, I thought that was fantastic.
John: Ah I love it Chris, thank you very much.
Alison: Chris has a very good anecdote well done.
John: Erwin Hirsch wrote to us, thank you Erwin.
"Hi Octothorpers.
Quick comment and slash or question on your latest podcast.
Did John's wife really have a rant about the state of the field of science fiction?
Did she really use those words or similar or is John verbaling her by applying that as a title?
I ask because a rant about Hugo nominations and nominators and where a work is categorized isn't a comment on the state of science fiction.
It's more like a comment on the bureaucracy that tends to beset awards."
And now it's time for a segment I like to call España's opinion on the state of the field of science fiction.
Dada da da dada dada dada jingle.
España: Well it absolutely is a comment on the state of the field because it's us and nonsense people who shape it so yeah.
Nonsense people.
John: This is España, listeners.
España: Hello.
John: She's new.
She's a guest.
Alison: I think we should say hello España, you're a guest on our podcast. It's very exciting.
Liz: Hello España.
España: Hello.
Yes instead of shouting from the other room I am shouting from inside the room.
John: *laughs*
So yes so we thought we would invite España on because Alison pointed out that it is the mumblebumble anniversary of Confrancisco which was the 1993 Worldcon.
España: 30 years man.
30 years.
Alison: Confrancisco was my first US Worldcon and I think it was España's first convention, is that right?
España: Yeah it was- I was 18, it was my first convention ever.
My first real brush with fandom.
Alison: And the reason I thought about this is that File 770, who do need a shout out for this and a link, have just done a very detailed recap of Confrancisco which includes a lot of things almost none of which I remember.
My memories are deeply deeply fragmentary thought hopefully when
España talks about all the marvelous things about Confrancisco which you will remember because it was our first convention
I will go, oh yes I remember that, but in fact I went back and looked at Abigail Frost's review which we'll also link to in Ansible and Abigail Frost who could make eating a sandwich extremely interesting in fan writing and funny, manages to not find anything very interesting to say about Confrancisco so I feel like
it might not have been a sparkling Worldcon. It put me off US Worldcons for a very long time.
España: Ooof. So I remember I remember it fragmentarily as well because obviously I didn't know what I was doing in- well, in my life obviously, but it's your first convention and there's a Worldcon and there's a lot going on so there's tons I missed. I don't think I went to the Hugos although I did go to the masquerade.
I remember it was very exciting and very big and a lot going on and like yay yay yay yay but also like I wouldn't have the perspective at the time and trying to back- you know, look back at it from the perspective of later Worldcons well obviously the difference is I know what I'm doing and I know more people.
John: Do you know what you're doing?
Alison: I really didn't know what I was doing at Confrancisco, it was so different to my experience of conventions, even Conspiracy which had been obviously a very big convention and a Worldcon and in the UK.
John: For listeners who don't know, Conspiracy was the 1987 Brighton Worldcon. Brighton and San Francisco, very similar cities in many ways.
España: So basically for those who don't know I grew up in Spain, I was born and raised in Spain and I moved to the States when I was 17.
I knew about fandom because I'd read various anthologies where the introduction talks about you know whoever the editor is it's like, "Oh we are at a party at the whatever Worldcon" or whatever convention so I knew that existed, and I very much wanted to have that and at the time in Spain there's no conventions there's no nothing,
what there was was like up in, you know, real cities. So when I got to the States there were it was the very beginning of the like internet or the web as we know it and there was internet connected chat tables at various cafes in the city.
So you could put like a quarter in and talk to people for 15 minutes. And the very first thing I type into one of those machines, I went to one of those machines, I put a quarter in, I was with my siblings for breakfast and I was like okay I'm gonna go do this now.
I don't think I talked to them the rest of the day and the first thing I typed in was "is anybody going to Worldcon? because I read in like F&SF or something like that that there was Worldcon happening in the city and I was like oh I'm very excited about this.
No one replied but like later on I found somebody who was in the SCA who was going to the Worldcon and was like oh yeah you should come along and all that and who knew about volunteering.
Which you know I think a lot of us agree is like the way to, if you're going into a convention for the first time, especially Worldcon, is the way to do it.
So that's what I did and I think he actually wanted to hook up with me.
I think that was the actual intent but you know it was still a very fortunate interaction.
John: I for one can't believe that you met someone in an SFnal context who wanted to hook up with you.
España: I know right?
John: Disgusting.
España: I wish I could remember his SCA name.
Liz: España would never hook up with anyone at Worldcon.
España: So podcasts aren't great for pointed stares but I'm doing a lot of that.
John: We met at a Worldcon listeners, and we're married.
And there's a picture of you which we'll put in the episode of you at the San Francisco Worldcon which is adorable because you've got like a little crop top on and you're all excited.
España: I remember I still have that crop top someplace because I just can't get rid of it.
I remember so I worked around the corner, San Francisco Shopping Center is right around the corner from the Moscone which was the place that the convention was held.
And so in that same shopping center there was a Ross Dress for Less which is like equivalent to like a TK Maxx or something.
I don't know what we have here.
So I remember being like I don't have anything to wear.
I was 18 at the time.
I wasn't going out much.
The age of drinking in the States is 21.
I didn't know anybody.
I remember going to Ross to find something that was like, I don't think I knew the concept of a fannish dress code.
But you know something appropriate too.
And I remember it's very 90s but I'm still very fond of it.
A little crop top with like that sort of English lace as a collar.
Whith a little like, you know, slightly lacy a bit.
Yeah.
And like flared sleeves and it was yeah.
It's dorky but I really love that top so much.
John: So Alison also volunteered at Confrancisco.
Alison: Yes. Somewhere there are photos and by Thursday I will have found a photo and and sent it to you of me at Confrancisco.
I was, I already knew by the time I went to Confrancisco
I already knew that I was Area Head for information desk for Glasgow in 1995.
I'd worked on the information desk at Confiction in the Hague in 1990 and really really enjoyed it.
And so when people were grubbing around for people who'd like to do jobs for the forthcoming UK Worldcon I was like oh I'd like to do your information desk.
Because I knew I was going to Confrancisco
I was like right that's where I'll work on Worldcon info desk.
And people are always like well why do you- isn't isn't it a bit much doing info desk all that, like, essentially public facing work for the whole weekend.
And I was like, at the time I worked on a Social Security counter.
So compared to working on a Social Security counter, information desk at conventions is the most fun ever because although people are you know a pain in the bum and exactly the same sort of way as they are in Social Security offices some of the time,
you tend to get, you tend not to get desperate people who can't eat and need money on information desks.
I mean sometimes you do but not so- you just point them at the con suite if you're at an American convention.
John: Alison telling that anecdote was an interesting one because I wanted to go to the 2005 Worldcon I would have been 16 and it would have been my first convention.
Because my mum and dad forbade it because they were like what's your plan for like eating and stuff.
I was like I've got to stay at a hostel and I'm just gonna buy a lot of weetabix and just eat weetabix for the whole weekend which listeners will realize is you know very much on brand and they were like no you can't possibly do that.
But if I had lived in the States it would have been a much easier sell because the con suite would have meant that that would have been food so I would have just needed to find a hostel and I would have been fine.
But yeah what did you volunteer to do.
España: So yeah so basically got there the guy who was trying to hook up with me saw me in my glasses after work like in my work uniform etc, I worked at a cafe around at the center etc, and was like nope.
But he did take the time to deposit me at - he didn't actually say nope he said it with his eyes.
John: That is so much worse.
España: Yes but deposit me at con ops and they it was very exciting like I was- it was at the Parc 55 and I was like there and there was like a lot of grown ups doing things and Forry Ackerman walked in and I'm like I know who that is and it was like yes.
And they sent me to - I don't know if they like gave me a choice or whatever - they sent me to sales to members which as you say having worked counter, in my case that's not that dissimilar to working at a cafe I guess just retail.
So the lady in charge of that was a big name fan, later on she took me to Baycon and stuff like that - Laurie Freeman at the time, she changed her name since.
John Did she change it to Anderson because that would be pleasingly symmetrical.
España: No. But yeah anyway so I worked Sales to Members during the day and then in the evening I worked for Robbie who you all know as a rover.
John: Robbie Bourget? España: Yes, Cantor at the time I believe.
John: Okay.
España: So yeah so I just like volunteered the entire weekend day and night and like commuted back and forth to the Sunset which is where I lived.
Alison: Oh no so I volunteered in the day but then when all that went up I went filking in the evening so I did a lot of filking at this convention.
España: I saw well, I don't know if you'll cut this, sadly she's controversial now but I saw Leslie Fish play at - that was my first experience of filk and I thought it was very good and very exciting because she is quite good and like again it was a name that I knew I don't even know why but yeah.
Alison: For listeners who don't know a lot about filk, Leslie Fish was just an extraordinary filk singer and composer who is completely round the bend in lots of ways and I was involved in running the filk cons, the early filk cons in the UK and I wasn't
too involved in the first one particularly except as a gopher but the first convention obviously invited Leslie Fish to be our Guest of Honour using a thing called the Flying Filk Fund which still exists because obviously she was the world's most exciting filker
and this is one of these things that are very famous in fandom now and she explained to us in the bar at that convention how she smuggled her gun in through customs into the UK.
España: Oh no.
Alison: And actually got the gun to show us and we were all like what the fuck, woman and I think at that point we started to realize that we may be had not made the perfect choice in our Guest of Honour and that was just a tiny part of how how absolutely bananas and outside of the general run of
filking Leslie Fish is and even was in 1993, it was already quite a thing even then.
John: So, so, hang on, so your at-con Confrancisco job was smuggling guns through customs, do I remember that right?
España: A hundred percent, yee haw. Oh no you're gonna you're gonna cut that out.
John: Now we have the jingle which is España going "Yee haw!" which is a noise you've never made before in my presence, which delights me.
Liz, how did you find Confrancisco?
Liz: Erm. Well I think, as we mentioned I would have been 10 years old. I had not even contemplated that fandom was a thing yet or probably read very much science fiction at this point.
España: That's nice for you.
Liz: Oh yeah, sorry España.
Come on I'm older than John!
Alison: What was your first US Worldcon Liz?
Liz: It would be Chicago 2012.
Alison: Yeah.
John: Mine was Reno in 2011.
Yeah.
Alison: And how did that go for you John.
John: Ah there was some woman who kept trying to pick me up.
España: But also it was held in a casino we were all drunk all the time so nobody knew any better John.
Alison:Yeah so one of the things about Confrancisco is that there were not a lot of drunk people around.
This is another joke about someone who is no longer with us, which is that Abi Frost put in her at reported in Ansible that there was no bar in the Moscone.
Moscone is a huge conference center and Martin Hoare reported that he'd found the bar in the Moscone and Dave Langford said yes but Martin Hoare could find the bar in the mosque which I think is true.
John: So what was your experience of alcohol at Confrancisco?
España: Alright so again I was 18 and drinking age in the States is 21, so I don't remember if I had anything to drink.
John: Yeah.
España: It was my introduction to parties but again as a rover.
I don't know if I found that very valuable at the time because obviously I didn't have any contrast but obviously in retrospect that was great. Because if I had not also been rover it's entirely possible that I would have gone to, you know, some evening events because like there was some stuff happening obviously like the masquerade,
but I might have just done Sales to Members all day, went around the convention and then gone home. But because I was rovering one of my jobs was going like along all the parties and just making sure like everything was okay which is a ridiculous responsibility for an 18 year old at her first convention but I was reasonably good at it.
And one of my only experience that I could remember of alcohol was one of the few useful things I did was helping an extremely drunk fan get out of an elevator. That was the entire thing just like "I can't get out of the elevator", I helped him get out of the elevator and off we went to the night.
John: "What is this cube!? Where am I?""
España: Well at the time I was like, maybe I should have done more than put him out in the street.
John: Well because at Reno you insisted on walking me back home.
España: Well I learned from my mistakes.
John: So like you and Schachat insisted that you accompany me from the Atlantis to the Peppermill, or maybe from the Peppermill or the Atlantis, that gets fuzzy, and then you took a taxi back but you were like outraged I had done the walk on my own and I was like it's just over there it's fine.
You were like "No! You are tiny! We will protect you!"
So yeah.
Alison: So back to Confrancisco parties - because I've been in fandom for quite a long time
I've been to two Worldcons and at Worldcons I have partied quite a lot and people were like oh yes but the parties are much better at US Worldcons than they are at UK Worldcons.
España: They are.
Alison: And they are - they are different and often better I mean I've been some amazing parties at US Worldcons right.
But my entire experience for the parties at Confrancisco was getting to the bottom of a very long elevator queue and going oh maybe I'll just go to the filking.
España: No there is a bit of that.
Alison: So I think I don't remember if that was a particular problem at that Worldcons or if that was or if I had just stuck with it
I would eventually have got to the front of that elevator queue and up to the party floor and to the parties.
España: No. Elevators at American conventions generally that is your main sticking point.
I don't know if it's as much of a problem here I guess but yeah it's always the thing.
I remember Chicago that being a thing and I remember, even Reno I remember going up and down the stairs a lot.
John: The thing is we don't have a lot of conventions here which are in big like hotel towers.
The only one I can remember it being a problem was the Mancunicon which was in a big tower.
And I seem to recall that there were like you occasionally had to queue for an elevator but like there's nothing like the Hyatt Regency in Chicago or anything where you've got like a massive old tower thing.
Even at Worldcons like - because Dublin had its fair share of problems with people and queuing, but like, there were loads of escalators in that main atrium, because it's much squatter.
Alison: So where we do have lifts the problem tends to be not that we have that "you're forced to use the lift because the hotel is very tall", it's normally the lift breaks because it was installed in 1841 and is made entirely of string
or whatever they make things out of, lifts out of, brass yeah. España: oats. John: oats.
Liz: So do we know if España and Alison cross paths at any point at Confrancisco and is it possible that when when Alison fishes out her photos will like España be in the background on one of your photos that's what I really want.
Alison: Well this is what we want to find out.
I don't know that there'll be very many photos because the other thing about photography in 1993 people also forget is that taking photographs inside was quite hard unless you had good kit which I definitely didn't.
So I'm not sure how many interior photos I have.
John: Well presumably there's very little exterior because surely it was pissing it down the entire time and when it wasn't it was fogging.
España: I don't remember if it rained, I don't think it did. Alison: So the weather was fine that's the other thing about San Francisco is that the things I remember about that trip was the holiday which was San Francisco which was an amazing city to just kind of knock around in.
John: Yes.
Alison: For a week, for a couple of weeks which is, I mean we made a couple of field trips out, but basically we stayed with fans outside of the convention so we only had to pay for our nights in the hotel.
The hotel was in the ANA which is one of the nicest hotels I've ever stayed in.
España: Yeah the convention was spread out over the Moscone or Moscone south I believe.
Or north? I don't know. One half of the convention centre because the convention center had not been finished.
John: Which is how the world goes.
Alison: Oh gosh yes I remember lots of roadworks now that you mentioned it.
Yes and walking past enormous caverns of excavation.
España: So we were like in just half of it, which is even less than nowadays because they've extended it to Moscone west.
So the Parc 55 was like operations I believe and then I think there's two other hotels, there's at least one other
which is where the parties were. So yeah there's a lot of like hustling back and forth which is, I mean I guess Dublin had that, but like yeah it's not,
some conventions handle that better than others. I don't know there's a way that they could have done it better as far as the geography.
John: I mean and there's no other, there will never, I mean it's vanishingly unlikely there will be another San Francisco Worldcon.
So like, you've got to do what you've got to do, if you want to have the Worldcon there right like.
España: No, and I got very lucky because Confrancisco was then, and like two years later there was an LA convention I want to say?
And then there was a San Jose one and then there was another LA one like relatively shortly together so I got kinda the pure product.
John: You didn't get it cut with any of this, like, other nonsense. No cutting it with anime or games.
Alison: I think we have a bunch of people who have had a whole load of European Worldcons on the trot who are getting into fandom now and have had that experience of having multiple accessible Worldcons over the last few years.
So that's quite nice. I've just remembered something else critical about that which is that in the in the lobby of the hotel we were staying at, there was a coffee cart, and it was my first experience of, you know, all of the coffee we drink all of the time now.
Lattes and cappuccinos and Americanos and all of them served from American style coffee carts and oh my god and I came back to Britain going "Shit, London needs this".
And if I had at that point gone "London needs this I should immediately go and raise some money", and opened - well somebody did open -
John: If you had opened a chain of coffee shops - listeners for those who don't know Alison is actually the CEO and co-founder of Costa Coffee.
ALison: Well Costa existed, I think Costa existed, one of them existed at the time but was crap.
So it was kind of, it was kind of, there was some but there wasn't, the the formula hadn't been properly developed at that point.
Oh but it was so good. I drank so much coffee. Need to drink so much coffee because I got about two hours sleep a night if I was lucky.
John: Oh yeah no that is that is a hundred percent true. Costa was founded in 1971.
Liz: Whoa. Alison: Yeah wasn't the same thing then.
John: No I imagine it wasn't. Alison: Coffee roasteries existed yeah but the whole "we are going to serve you hot frothy milk drinks with some coffee in very large quantity to commuters fast" that didn't exist.
That was the thing that was just getting off the ground. John: But yeah so Worldcons.
España: Approved. John: Yay good! Thanks very much for coming on the podcast España. España: Bye. Bye.
John: Do you, well I should ask Liz, do you have anything else you want to say to España. Liz: Hi España!
John: Okay so someone's written in the show notes that Glasgow's got a big organ. Which of you, which of you is responsible for this and can you explain yourselves.
Liz: I put that in the show notes because they're going to have Interstellar with the music played over it by the organist who recorded the soundtrack.
Who is an acclaimed pipe organist. Alison: Oh that's great.
Liz: And they've got a pipe organ. Well they're going to do it somewhere with a pipe organ I don't think that is the SEC, but somewhere in Glasgow will have a pipe organ.
Alison: I assume that somewhere that's there's going to be some fantastic pipe organ in Glasgow. Liz: Yeah and the Interstellar soundtrack is great, I listen to it quite a lot as my sort of background music and it has some great organ music in it.
Yeah and they're going to have that and talk about how that came about and how the organist Roger Sayer got involved with being the organist on Interstellar.
So that sounds quite cool. John: That does sound quite cool. Alison: That does sound excellent.
When I've been to gigs which I do go to sometimes, when a band plays to accompany a film it's always been a silent movie because you think well how are they going to patch through the dialogue.
John: My argument would be that Chris Nolan you already can't hear the dialogue so why not whack an organ over the top. Is that helpful? A joke.
Liz: I'm wrong it's just a performance of the score. Not with the film. Sorry. John: Boo.
Alison: That is good. So it is just it is just an audio performance of the score rather than a thing patched through to the film.
Liz: It sounds like it yes. John: Listeners, if you want, download Interstellar onto your phone and attend that programme item while watching the film.
Alison: You will not irritate anybody when you do this. Better yet take your VR headset and put your VR headset on and watch Interstellar on your VR headset whilst listening to the performance. That will work and will not irritate people and be properly SFnal although people will think you're a bit weird.
John: Full disclosure, it will definitely irritate someone, I just don't know who, but if you will be irritated write in.
Alison: Yeah but they don't - it's not, it's non-justifiable irritation because this is not irritating to sit quietly with a VR headset on in a way that is incredibly annoying to sit quietly with a phone on during an audio performance.
John: Glasgow have a rate rise at the end of September and I am doing a panel for Glasgow Presents which is on "The Media of Storytelling: Print Versus Screen" and that will be on the 21st of September 2023.
We will put a link in the show notes. It starts at 7pm British time and I will be moderating and the people appearing will be Dan Hanks, AM Justice, Jim McLeod and RWW Green.
So if you are a fan of any of those people or of the concept of storytelling do come along. If you're planning to be at the Third Thursday Zoom that day my recommendation is to have a bunch of beer, come along, and then heckle at me in the Zoom after.
Alison: It's funny, that was my exact plan for that evening.
John: Hey great minds.
Alison: You could tell everyone about the virtual Zoom. You could plug the virtual Zoom on your on your event.
John: I will. I will indeed. I will promote it. I'll be like, Alison Scott's running an official after party.
That won't annoy anyone.
Alright and now it's time for picks.
Liz: I got a pick. I'm going to pick a book. So you know how I said last time that I read a ton of books, I'm gonna pick another one of the books I read because it's good.
Thank you again to Niall Harrison for providing this book. The book is Walking Practice by Dolki Min and it was originally written in Korean and has been translated by Victoria Caudel.
It's a short novel, maybe long novella, about a shape shifting alien who gets stranded on earth and they have to hunt for food.
And their food is people and it's kind of all first person perspective of this shape shifting alien who shape shifts into different bodies and forms in order to essentially hunt humans mostly through one night stands.
Yeah and it's kind of all about their psychology. The sort of the psychology of taking someone else's shape and what you take on.
They- you know they also it's kind of an allegory for like, sexuality and gender because they shape shift their appearance and shift their sexuality according to what they need.
And it's quite cleverly translated. There are what must have been quite difficult to translate kind of typographic effects to try and get through the state of mind of the alien.
And yeah it's just, it's quite quirky, it's quite fun, it is quite horrific, it is basically a novel in which you're following the protagonist round as they kill and eat people and I really enjoyed it. It doesn't feel like anything else I've read.
And so I enjoyed it.
John: Nice.
Alison: Okay so I have been Hugo reading and the thing about the Hugos this year is that the Hugo novels, one of them is the third in a set of four books and if you haven't read the previous two I'm not sure
the third one will make any sense at all.
And if you have read the first two then - and this is one of the things about Tamsyn Muir's novels, the third one may not make that much sense but we're going to talk about that in our Hugo podcast - but I've read Gideon the Ninth and Harrow the Ninth.
And I liked them both quite a lot so these are the Locked Tomb novels. I think we probably will talk about all three novels when we do it on the Hugo episode so I won't talk about any more of that but I did two other prerequisites. For The Spare Man by Mary Robinette Kowal
I went and watched The Thin Man which is a film from 1934 with I believe no genre elements at all unless you believe in a preternaturally cute dog.
But it is a very funny film which will only take you an hour and a half. I would strongly recommend that. The Spare Man has a set of a pair of married detectives which is a nod to Nick and Nora Charles in The Thin Man. The Thin Man was produced immediately after prohibition and this is something that you can see through the movie because everybody in this movie drinks constantly.
I mean not everybody but the heroes drink constantly and that's, I don't know, it looks quite odd to modern eyes and I found had two takes on this neither of which are original to be but neither of which I can remember who said them first so sorry.
The first is it is now extremely unusual to see a movie in which people are - an American movie certainly I think slightly more common in British movies but still not that common - where people are drinking and having fun where drinking is a thing that adults do for fun rather than some kind of evidence of a character who is going into decline or some other disaster will befall them because of their alcoholism.
None of that happens here, they drink, it's fun, which is my experience of drink. And the other thing that I saw was it's quite unusual to have a movie where a marriage is neither a goal nor an obstacle because the heroes of this film are a happily married couple who start off happily married, carry on being happily married, and end the film happily married.
That's not any part of what the film is about it is a detective story about a happily married couple who are happy and it's very funny.
So that was the, so that was one prerequisite and the other prerequisite was The Island of Doctor Moreau by H.G. Wells which is a novel which builds from Victorian adventure stories and has a adventure story where the island that our hero is cast away on turns out to have something
nefarious going on and the plot of the novel that you first of all find out what is going on and learn about it then it all falls apart because you have to have a plot, it doesn't have a huge amount of plot, but that is the plot so far as it is.
It's really quite good for its age I think.
This H.G. Wells, he was good at what he did, who knew.
So it is obviously Victorian with all of the things that that implies and the plot is a little bit thin and some of the writing's a bit strange and some of the attitudes are a bit weird
but not as weird as a lot of Victorian writing and I really enjoyed that quite a lot as well and that is the prerequisite for The Daughter of Doctor Moreau but in that case, and in fact I'm not sure I'd recommend doing either of these as prerequisites so for, for Nona the Ninth
you do have to read the first two first. Don't bother reading this novel if you haven't read the first two but for The Spare Man and The Daughter of Doctor Moreau I think you're completely fine not to do the prerequisites.
With The Daughter of Doctor Moreau I think you'll get slightly more out of it if you go back in time and read the Wells about three or four years ago so you have read it but it's not fresh in your mind.
For The Spare Man I think you should not probably not watch The Thin Man until after you've read The Spare Man, they don't have anything in common but I just don't think it in I don't think having seen The Thin Man recently enhances that novel at all.
John: There, I was not intending to do the movie or the Wells as homework but hurrah rather you did and can talk about it on the pod and obviously I had already read the Ninths on account of previous years Hugo whatdoyoucallems.
Liz you've read the 9th. Have you done the Wells or the movie?
Liz: Nope, not doing any extra homework.
John: Fair enough.
Liz: I'm going to be hard pushed to read all the Hugo stuff before the actual Hugo voting deadline so. John: I've finished novel but I haven't finished the others yet.
I'm going to pick a movie and I'm going to pick a movie that has two versions and I'll talk about both of them a little bit.
So I'm going to pick Invasion of the Body Snatchers so the original of this movie was made in 1956 directed by Don Segal starring Kevin McCarthy and Dana Winter and then the remake was 1978 directed by Phillip Kaufman starring
Donald Sutherland, Brooke Adams and a very young Jeff Goldblum and Leonard Nimoy.
Both of them are very well cast obviously the cast of the more recent remake is more recognizable to modern audiences.
Leonard Nimoy plays an excellent psychiatrist where you will genuinely have trouble with the question "Bad guy or mansplainer? which is a great dichotomy to have in your Leonard Nimoy character.
I will say so I like both movies, they both kind of stand up, I enjoyed both of them but the older one is a lot tighter.
The new one's like almost two hours long and the old one, the 50s one is 80 minutes and the new one doesn't really introduce enough extra to make the extra 40 minutes feel necessary or good and certainly the beginning of the movie has cinematography in it which is actively
distracting, it's like what were they going for with these shots like I admire the effort to do something artistic but it doesn't quite land. But it's frustrating because the cast are great like Donald Sutherland is amazing, I didn't know he used to have brown curly hair.
I've only seen him in movies more recently where he does not have that so that was very exciting and Jeff Goldblum must be like in his early twenties he's stick thin and very young and it's nice to kind of just see him as a young boy
and Donald Sutherland and Brooke Adams have amazing chemistry. Unfortunately the pacing of the movie is very weird because there's just a lot of build up of tension and then kind of nothing really happens for a little bit and so the tension doesn't really work for the movie
whereas in the original the tension kind of builds and builds and builds and builds and builds and it's really well paced and the movie does a very good job with making you feel very uneasy.
So I think if I was going to recommend one of them I'd recommend the original the 1956 version but both are good and as I say the casting and the chemistry in the '78 version is amazing but we have just watched the 1978 version
so yeah I thought I would pick it. This is part of my going through the Time Out top 100 list of science fiction films these two are both on it which is actually, like, for a list that doesn't have Fury Road but does have Road Warrior it's quite surprising
that there's not many instances of a film in its remake being on there but this is one of them and Solaris is one of them.
Alison: I think it is it is often true that older films are shorter - obviously there are long older films here and there but a lot of films that would have been made in 80 or 90 minutes are now made in two hours 15 minutes and you think well maybe this could have been a tad tighter.
You don't get the opportunity to see what the film would have been like if it had been tightly edited but the old films were shorter because film was so, you know, film was very expensive
John: When the corollary to this is Solaris which I mentioned where I think the older of those two is like pushing three hours and the remake is like a tight two and I haven't watched the one pushing three hours yet because every time I sit down to watch a movie and I see the runtime I'm like I can do like literally anything else.
That was the Octothorpe podcast and it's goodbye from me. Alison: It's goodbye from me. Liz: And it's goodbye from me.
Liz: I'm very excited because I get to see John all the time but I don't get to see España apart from when she kind of wafts in with pancakes and coffee for you.
Alison: So I do sometimes get to see España on a different Zoom but it's nice to see España hello España!
Have you got your audio in yet España?
John: She's on her way.
Alison: So no then.
John: We're going to share headphones.
Liz: Oh you're going to have one earbud each like when I was a kid and we used to share earbuds on a Walkman.
Alison: This is like channeling 90s, well 1983 rather than 1993.
John: I'm going to do a Letter of Comment and then you're going to know how to respond.
Liz: España looks so like "I'm here. I'm here under duress."
John: España isn't whatchamacallit, España isn't angry yet but when I wind her up and let her go.
That's when it will be good right?
España: You could just be nice.
John: How many episodes of "Geek Girl Crafts" did you do?
España: Oh god.
John: Okay.
Alison: How many episodes of what?
John: Because España was a podcaster before I was a podcaster.
España: Yes. I used to do a crafting podcast with my friends in the Bay Area.
Alison: You need to move that microphone so it is nearer España than you.
John: I'm louder than you basically.
España:  Hello.
John: But also the thing is she will get louder.
So there is like a balancing act here.
The theme music for this episode was Surf Shimmy by Kevin MacLeod at incompetech.com used under a Creative Commons attribution 4.0 license.
Liz: This podcast will end at the beep.
John: Beep!